hey hey hey girlfriend what's up you
want a straw I'm not dummy one who sucks
too sexy right hi I'm sure did you know
that 500 million we are used in the US
per day per day Sheeler predict I'm too
small for the recycling machine so I
can't get recycled IRA coffee cups did
you know that an estimated 16 billion of
me end up in landfills across the u.s.
the u.s. each year
styrofoam you might think I have it all
you know because I made a favor and I'm
recyclable not only my liver my sleeve
are recyclable because baby the inside
of me is all plastic but tell people
because they're not recycling me right
hi i'm possib back i only you're more
than a trillion of me or using thrown
away around roll over your Twilio uneven
fun listen to me Marie
each year eight million tons of plastic
end up in the ocean I love the office I
hope your sheets me so I end up on your
dinner table hello my name is whatever
you look very thirsty dehydrated it's a
hot day so I could use some more easily
accessible another same
you know globally you humans by a
million of me each minute
one minute for a freshman
Angus one only 9% of the plastic produce
gets recycled it came us we plastics
take 400 years to break down you can
never get rid of me hi I'm takeout if
I'm covered in decrease even when he
tried to recycle me I just end up in a
landfill what do you want me to do about
it
wash me out
look at this Jess you can't recycle this
you know the average American makes
about four point four pounds a trash a
day they always say reduce reuse recycle
but don't forget about the reduce
reduces important it's what I'm going on
a vacation to the Galapagos I hope they
end up in the sea turtles nose
[Music]